C'est le Mondial.
Champion du monde c'est mon destin.
Passement de jambes, c'est un festin.
Tire en lulu, c'est la fiesta.
Milieu de terrain comme Andrès...
Iniesta.
Un petit pont ça fait du mal.
Chez nous ça vise que les finales.
Ta copine me kiffe tu le vis mal.
Parce que je suis beau gosse comme Antoine...
De Saint Exupéry !
Griezmann !
Tir de loin, rien que c'est précis.
J'ai l'impression que t'apprécies.
Même tout petit dans la téci...
On m'appelait Léo...
Nardo DiCaprio !
Messi !
Ouais.
Messi.
C'est ce que j'ai dit, j'ai dit Messi.
On m'appelait Léo Messi.
Je sais, le joueur de... football.
Je sais, je suis pas...
Foulard.
Vas-y, fais le coup du foulard.
STOP !
Foulard.
J'en ai marre de cacher...
Cet énorme secret.
Je ne connais rien au foot.
Mais je fais semblant pour être accepté.
A certains moments je crie "hors-jeu".
Quand on me dit "t'es pour qui ?" je dis "les Bleus".
Pour moi une "bicyclette" c'est avant tout un moyen de transport très ingénieux.
Je vois très bien qui est Zidane.
Non, je suis pas fou.
Je vois un peu moins qui est Fekir.
C'est un peu flou.
Je vois très bien qui est Cristiano Ronaldo.
Un brésilien qui aujourd'hui est un peu gros.
Je suis pas le plus calé en football.
Je veux juste crier "but" chaque fois qu'on marque un goal.
Je veux crier but.
But.
Je veux juste crier but.
Si tout comme moi t'as déjà offert un maillot.
Avec une faute d'orthographe floquée dans le dos.
Sache que tu n'es pas seul.
Si tout comme moi lorsqu'on t'a proposé d'faire un five.
Tu pensais que c'était faire un tcheck qui assure grave.
Sache que tu n'es pas seul.
Nan, nan.
On voit très bien qui est Pogba on n'est pas fou.
On voit moins bien qui est Thauvin.
C'est un peu flou.
On sait très bien ce qu’est une aile de pigeon.
C’est ce qui permet de voler à un pigeon.
Je suis pas le plus calé en football.
Je veux juste crier "but" chaque fois qu'on marque un goal.
Je veux crier but.
Je veux crier but !
But.
Bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-bu-but.
Je veux juste crier but.
Si tu connais rien au foot sache qu'on est comme toi.
On veut simplement pouvoir vivre des moments de joie.
On se dit que la Coupe du monde en Russie...
Bah y devrait faire froid.
On a pas d'autre analyse.